Grammy's you watch the Grammys last
night wasn't that something what's not a
good show the Grammys I got I got these
I really got the impression they didn't
watch this there was a weird pause and
then just sort of an automatic okay this
is a television show I guess we watched
it and they're being helpful they're
being helpful I don't think a lot of
people watched it yeah and these guys
definitely not they didn't know I was
excited I was I don't you know this I
was all set to host the Grammys but at
the last minute I was never asked why
I'm the last person in the world that
you know can imagine the confusion if I
hosted the Grammys fivers what are you
fantastic to be here and then launched
into a tune I still say if you believe
it you can do it you should have been
there very nice for you oh you're gonna
be ass I think you should just show up
there and try and home though it's nice
that you gave me that support but you
also said that when you said that I
could host the Latin Grammys that's
right
turned out not to be true also yeah the
Grammys were last night or as my parents
call it the who are they who anybody is
listen I don't know who anybody is how
my mother loves to change though like to
change her doesn't sound anything like
that but for the purpose of comedy my
mom sounds like to change Grammys it was
a great show a lot of exciting results
don't ask me how but the winner for best
album was Tom Brady I don't know how
that guy
[Applause]